okay I've got new book recommendations
for you today I used to do a once a week
book recommendation segment and it never
did that well I it wasn't ever like a
super popular segment but the people
that liked it really liked it so after
being on hiatus for a long period of
time the book recommendation is book
recommendations are back each every
couple of weeks I'll recommend a couple
of fiction books and a couple of
non-fiction books remember that you can
go to david pakman.com slash
recommendations for my full list of
recommendations and anything you buy
through the links at david pakman.com
slash recommendations supports us all so
I have to be careful about how I word
this if you use those links and then you
end up buying other things on Amazon as
well that will also support us I want to
be careful that I'm in compliance of the
Amazon affiliate agreement I'm also
going to make an effort to add some
commentary next to some of my
recommendations about what they are or
why I like them or whatever okay so
let's start with the non-fiction books
today first one the book is in order to
live by yummy Park this is another one
of these somewhat controversial books
about someone who escaped North Korea
and like many of the books by North
Korean escapees there are questions
about the accuracy of some of the
elements of the story but nevertheless a
fascinating fascinating read in order to
live by yon me Park read it not long ago
very quick read type of thing you can
read on a flight or on a relatively
short vacation excellent excellent book
that I recommend you check out and then
there's a couple of others at david
pakman.com slash recommendations that
are other north korean escapee stories
very very interesting ok switching gears
drastically to the healthcare debate
this is a book by the late great yui
Reinhardt and the book is called priced
out the economic and ethical costs of
American health care this is a book that
is not one of these partisan pop
politics books that is either about
single-payer is socialism
or you know single-payer is the only way
forward or whatever this is an academic
book but it's not difficult read and
it's quite short in fact it's only about
if you don't include the epilogue and
the notes it's under a hundred and forty
pages okay
very short book and it outlines the
academic economic mathematical case
forgetting definitely off of the health
care system we have really good
ammunition to be armed with if you are
going to be talking about health care
with anybody again the book is priced
out by UE Reinhardt
all right there's that those are my two
nonfiction recommendations let me do two
fiction recommendations the first one is
this is not a new book this is the
trigger by arthur c clarke and micheal
cube McDowell maybe it's QB McDowell the
concept here what year is this book from
this book is from 1999 it's a 20 year
old book at this point the concept is a
research lab comes across a technology
that would disable all firearms when a
device is placed in proximity it's
almost like a mobile phone jammer except
it's a firearm jammer and at first it
seems like this is going to be a
fantastic thing for this is fiction by
the way just restating that this is
going to be a fantastic thing for
stopping gun violence it could be used
by militaries to fight wars without
weapons being used the idea of it sounds
fantastic but then arthur c clarke as he
is known to do gives us the other side
of seemingly utopian circumstances and
does not any political statement
implicit in what i'm saying this is just
what the story is the trigger by arthur
c clarke
written along with michael cube McDowell
excellent book twenty years old
extremely still relevant today and
lastly another fiction book the gone
world by Tom sweater lish this book was
recommended to me by Joe Rogan's guest
Booker when I was on the Rogan program
we talked about different sci-fi that we
had been reading and Joe's guest Booker
got in touch with me and said hey this
is a really great book the gone world
that you should check out and it is it's
a sort of time travel detective novel
and it is really really great I ended up
picking up some other books by Tom
sweater lish after I read this one the
gone world toms sweater lish all of
these recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations use the
links there so that everything you buy
supports the david pakman show and I'll
be adding and expanding that page more
going forward